[Music]
I'm excited to have Priyanka Vergara a
customer engineer at Google cloud here
with me to show us how to set up service
level monitoring and stackdriver hi
franca hi Stephanie thank you for having
me thank you
Google has published our practices for
managing reliable services at scale in
site reliability engineering books and
this sre workbook one of the main
principles of sre is using service level
objectives can you show us how
developers can do the same yeah let's
dive right in and let me show it through
a demo okay great perfect so I have this
website here that is built to order some
stuff and so I'm gonna put something in
the cart and it's it's an e-commerce
website it lets you order things and
then it places an order so I have my
credit card information in there and we
just placed an order now behind the
scenes there's a lot going on in this
particular application so if we look at
what's going on here this is the service
architecture of the application and it
is talking it has a front-end and has
various different services talking to
the front-end
check out the catalog the product
catalog the card service this is a lot
that's going on here and if you see
further they're pretty much all written
in very different languages as well so
there's a lot of complexity behind the
scenes that's that's going on and this
is all done through micro services as
you as you can see so it's it's
important to understand that a simple
website is set up with with different
lengths can be set up with different
services in the backend and have
different languages that it can be
written in so complexities right and
micro servers architectures mean the app
itself is broken into many small pieces
and doesn't that make it hard to
understand how all the pieces fit
together and where to start
investigating when there is a problem
it's very it becomes very hard for the
operations team especially in micro
services architecture to figure out
what's going on which services is up
down talking to each other so it there's
a good tool in stackdriver monitoring
called
topology where you can actually look at
the topology of your different micro
services talking to each other so I have
a
been here and when you open the service
topology I can look at a specific
service that I'm interested in and then
see which other services it is talking
to so it gives me a view I can click on
one and it gives me a view of what's
going on and which services it is
talking to you which is pretty helpful
when you're working in an environment
that has so many different services
micro services that it's talking to well
and this is great because with micro
service based apps you can clearly see
the inter-service dependencies and use
that to double-check new code rollouts
but let's say you're setting up alerts
op staff can burn out a lot of the times
from getting notified of all the
potential causes of a problem making it
hard to align S aureus with customer
interests how can we identify which
behaviors really actually matter for
that service during service degradation
yeah so there is also another tool
within stat driver monitoring for
services where you can actually set up
SL o--'s and define which define your s
allows for the services so operations
does not actually get affected by just
looking at all the different alerts that
that can come by it's actually a
practice within our sre teams where we
make sure that our there are a sorry
staff is only monitoring alerts that are
related to customer issues and and
front-end customer related issues and
not every single issue that might be it
might be a cause to those issues so
let's let's see that in a in the demo as
well yeah so if we click on services
here in the staff driver monitoring
let's look at front-end and when we go
do that you're able to see the service
level optimization so let me click on s
loz and in SLO as you obviously see
nothing here so we're going to set one
up and say we want to set up for
availability and then there is we can do
a rolling or calendar I want to say in
the month if we reach 99% or no
availability then I want to get alerted
that is that's a good way of saying that
you're not gonna be alerted for
everything but you still want to be
alerted for when we go
less than 99% and then you can also set
up a latency alert so in this case if we
say latency and I want to set up
differently for different services for
the front-end you could say my pager
should load in less than thousand
milliseconds otherwise I want to be
notified and in this case also let's say
it's 90% our goal and then we submit
that so these are the two alerts that we
just set up for latency and availability
and they are not just thresholds because
we are saying this percentiles so it's
not going to be charged at E and noisy
it's going to be if this happens then we
really want to get notified because the
service is not working fine
so that's that's a good way of
identifying making sure that you're not
burning out your your operations to
excellent how do you follow these best
practices given the resources that you
have yeah so you also have metrics and
Diagnostics in there so if you click on
metrics you're able to see the request
count and the response latency is which
which will guide you through the request
and response and if you click on
Diagnostics that actually takes you to
the trace so now if I want to drill
deeper into the 95th percentile which is
probably the one I want to look at
because it's not performing very well
then I can click on that and see a
specific request why it was slow for for
what reasons and which requests were
actually so so in this case we can see
that the checkout service was a little
bit slow in send and receive so we may
want to do deeper into that and find out
what's going on there so the Diagnostics
tab and the metrics tab are really good
friends for troubleshooting great and at
some point you probably need to dig a
little deeper into the services signals
let's say maybe you received an SLO
alert and there's no obvious upstream
cause or you have a customer complaint
outside of an SLO alert that you need to
investigate or maybe you need to see how
the new rollout of your code version is
going how do you get a coherent display
of all the signals for a specific
service yeah so I think the best the
best thing to do at that point is you
you got an alert through SLO you want to
look at metrics and Diagnostics to kind
of figure out what's going on because
metrics and diagnostic
going to be helpful to understand which
specific services not performing well as
you can see in Diagnostics when we drill
deeper into a specific service we were
able to find out that checkout is the
culprit and so we can drill deeper into
that so those metrics and Diagnostics
would be your great friends in order to
find out what's actually going on so
stackdriver service monitoring gives you
a whole new way to view your application
architecture reason about its customer
facing behaviors and get to the root of
any problem that arises so thank you so
much for younger for showing us how
Google is transforming the opps
experience of cloud native and micro
service deployments thank you for having
me it was fun
[Music]
you